to businessmen bought the Milwaukee
Bucks for 550 million dollars they are
very excited with their purchase as this
is the only legal way to own black
people now that is here and I read that
well you're not there you know how
businessman our racist they are yes it's
them being racist they are to that the
two businessmen they bought the
Milwaukee Bucks for 550 million dollars
yeah a racist according their how many
people getting sicker than a Hindu
obstacle course at the airport it's just
it is I mean I'm a racist but is it's
it's getting and I don't mind foreigners
but don't be from your cut like from
your country like it's okay to be
originally from there like your parents
and Grandpa but you can't be from India
and even that was from evil devil ID you
know what the [ __ ] no I'm American I
gotta be more American than you cuz I
don't know even level that is even a
little ID boarding pass
man I know my voice rules I'm American
like I need another I need an American
voice to ask me for my [ __ ] but you
can't get rid of the Doubleday news cuz
they're amazing like who else will work
at a 24-hour Brooklyn gas station with
no bulletproof vests and no gun
and cursed [ __ ] out if they don't have
less than a 50 i bable bable bable you
need something smaller please baby
double duple duple day you can't get rid
of a because they do jobs nobody else is
going to that's why you can't realism
what is this thing when we trying to get
Mexicans out this country who else is
going to work without Mexicans and who
is going to work
who else would drive a bicycle on the
highway who also ratified
we're also rider women who also ride a
bicycle on the highway against traffic
to deliver you a panini sandwich for
lunch on time
it's gonna kick in your hotel door to
make your bed besides a little Mexican
woman who has an ethic she has to make
your bed I have to I have to make hello
and she knocks did she [ __ ] punches
the door and she scares the [ __ ] out she
kicks the [ __ ] door and the chain is
on hello hello and your legs mister
chain is I'm alive the chains on the
door you don't have ma'am please look
and I please I must make your bed I must
make your bed I must make you bed I feel
and she's trying to squeeze in through
the space through the chain space I wish
I never travel for over room because I
could I would like to just never had
travel outside this country and then I
could hate America
and be happy you know I'm saying but I
travel and I was like I'm now at like
America but I still hate it's weird I
hate it but there's no way better cuz
all I got to really deal with his racist
crackers like that and that's that's
funny because like I don't black people
really don't look at white people wit
like you're the oppressor anymore it's
just something I do it's just like we
like not liking white people and white
people like not liking us it's like is
this what we do is just because I'm not
going nowhere and I'll kill him I was
lucky told me to go like back to Africa
listen I'm talking to black people stop
that [ __ ] war [ __ ] that go back to
Africa [ __ ] first of all Africans don't
like black people that's first of all
they don't like this and what the [ __ ]
am I gonna do in Africa besides fighting
some war wearing sweat pants and tuxedo
shoes with a [ __ ] [ __ ] machete in
my hand with a pair of [ __ ] tuxedo
shoes and a knife fighting some goofy
ass [ __ ] the war [ __ ] gym neighbor
was jimping that is my neighbor a nice
fella
nice guy let me come on that's not a
Chinese guy I wasn't seeing it was kind
of really Mickey Rooney I know he's dead
but Mickey Rooney did a very racist
thing like you just did in a movie
called Breakfast at Tiffany's by the
wonderful Truman Capote I wasn't doing
anything racist and you know it I
learned a lot last year about one of
your great American heroes Rosa Park it
was the 200 year celebration of the
abolition of slavery in Britain last
year we were a bit ahead of you on that
but well done
Boggan but the abolition of slavery
wasn't the end of racism racism was
still inherent in society as late as the
fifties and sixties in England and
America and it was this one incident
that sparked off the civil rights
movement a young black woman called Rosa
Park refused to give up her seat to a
white person on a bus it was the law but
she'd had enough and she was arrested
for that but then that law was changed
but she didn't stop there
she started sitting in those seats meant
for disabled people
[Applause]
she talked the driver when the bus was
in motion did she have the correct
change really did she bollocks
Oh some people Cheers you know that was
my grandmother's thing that really
cleaning up as a Negro spiritual black
work song not everybody know about that
see white people you guys my whistle
when you work but that's how you can
tell what kind of work we're actually
doing
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's that it kind of I do anything
that has to do with race I read a little
here see a little there and I travel
that's always good
traveling has made me a racism
connoisseur if you will you know it's
different from region to region anyone
ever been down south so you guys know
what I'm talking about
and the racism down there it's just
still do a perfection bull it's out the
open there are no secrets in Mississippi
everybody knows the deal morning sir
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that up here you hit the big cities man
it's different it's always a secret then
we should do like then we should keep
out that I know when been a little I
mean with limits you don't want to say
whatever comes to your mind that might
be a little much
why do be walking down the street man in
this business brother walk up to hello
you right oppressor you slave master
rapist of Africa Teague why hello my big
lip spear chucking Freddie okay so why
do what did you do today huh a press a
new land and make the people there
Christians against their will what did
you do fellow burn those big black lips
on a crack pipe as your least your job
it'll be easy why do you cut deep well
this chitchat has got me thirsty
you will excuse me for a moment I'm
gonna go to the Korean store get
something to drink
[Music]
hello you spanner dad ruin the economy
on our neighborhood by opening stores
and taking the money out the community
cheek good afternoon you browse around
but never buy anything
can't allow that might be too much
she can't help it if you an American
you're racist we brought up from the
beginning to think in generalizations we
never look at them never visual we
rarely look at individual I'm a racist I
know I'm a race there's no how no the
other day I caught myself being racist
against myself there's some one kid
knowing I got mixed up forgot whose team
I was on what time I was reading the
paper man his story came on about the UH
this guy was suing a department store
because they wouldn't let him play Santa
Claus you know cuz he's black and I was
actually like relieved when a department
store beat oh that's bad
but I wasn't ready for that I wasn't
ready for the idea of a black Santa
Claus man it would suck we wouldn't get
our presence to the 28/29
sorry kids
Santa got caught up with them I had to
sell some toys to get back cookies
but when a willing victim who is
committed adultery he reads his pills
and a traitor stands
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]